bonjour bonjour à tous si loïc le
cadreur monteur influenceurs de renom
petit message à caractère informatif
après un terrible crash de disque dur
nous pensions cette vidéo perdu pour
toujours dans le méandre du néant
mais grâce aux progrès du monde moderne
nous avons réussi à la retrouver
malheureusement ce n'est que du 720p
comme vous allez rapidement le
comprendre elle a été tournée début
décembre 2018
certaines références sont donc dater il
n'empêche que nous vous la proposons ici
et aujourd'hui pour votre plus grand
bonheur à vous amateurs de casse-tête
allez bisous bisous
comme dirait l'autre bonjour je suis
fabien de chehoudi carglass
j'adore vos seins trop que vont proposer
aujourd'hui on va se faire
quid le clip c'est quoi c'est une deux
trois quatre cinq disques en
superposition dans le 5e n'a que peu
d'importance dont le but est de trouver
la position ultime pour que toutes les
parts de ce petit gâteau soit égal à la
même somme c'est aussi bête que ça
presse à coup ça change un petit peu je
sais pas si c'est dur ou pas je pense
elle que aussi du hasard on peut
peut-être tâtonner mais je me suis dit
ok c'est cool on va se le faire du coup
faut que je fasse attention à ce que
vous puissiez bien voir tu as reçu vous
voyez pas authier ben moi je vois mes
seins première c'est de répondre lui
comme moi c'est un rêve si c'est que moi
qui réponds acquise sur iphone on est
passé à des problématiques qui se posent
et après on peut pas savoir quelle heure
ils aiment matin je suis quoi toi la
semaine prochaine je te fais un défi qu
à steph je te défie au casse tête
charline succès mercredi prochain à six
heures comme tous les mercredis à 6
heures bienvenue chez lui car steve
policard cet espace human sanou pas
voter dans les commentaires sur une note
de 1 à 1 milliard si ça sonne pas de
l'iran licka hockey écoute
cast est somme toute très simple que
vous pouvez retrouver dans la
description si vous intéresse je leur
sers et un petit peu quand même
je vous mets un petit lien des familles
c'est quoi sa difficulté le jeu
déjà je vais le chercher et puis je vais
vous dire si je le retrouve comme ils
s'appellent petit casse tête qui ne
casse tête du prix de 24,90 ne s'est pas
donné un van pour cinq disques en bois
c'est une difficulté extrême de 4 sur 5
il est considéré comme étant lui-même un
casse tête mathématique les commentaires
ne sont pas très élogieux
je découvre maintenant très déçu je très
petit mauvaise qualité au public déjà
livré sans solution bah oui quelqu'un
camille sans solution est vrai gros
doutes sur sa faisabilité à puisque dès
que je pense avoir trouvé hier devant
une casse de fausses de l'an aulas
n'achetez pas bon j'ai écouté le chant
sur amazing donc pas aimé ce casse tête
moi comme je lis jamais les commentaires
bah comme un gros blair jeu lâcheté et
si on s'aperçoit à la fin que j'y arrive
pas je ferais comme eux je mettrai une
critique comme quoi mais allez pas
faisable se trouve c'est parti pour
cette nouvelle journée
donc là je vais le positionner au pif
déjà pour voir donc on voit que déjà il
ya deux séquences possible sur ces deux
disques là sur ce disque et sur ce
disque qui va falloir trouver quelle est
la bonne séquence donc et sur ce disque
là donc il ya trois disques compte
double séquence possible pour former les
quatre lignes et au final nous formerons
le chiffrage universel total biais de
jeunes c'est pas con il ya combien de
position déjà un 16 17
j'ai compté au pavillon louis jacques
comptait peut-être un terreau lots 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 14 15 16
il ya 16 position de quatre lignes de
faire le même résultat
les chiffres et les nombres vont de un
pour le plus bas et qu'elle est le plus
gros pour l'instant que je vois c'est 27
revue plus gros 27 hockey le plus gros
c'est 27 et le plus bas c'est un donc je
vais partir de la ligne donne cette
[ __ ] bien trouver une méthodologie là
tout seul dans ma tête donc 27 et deux
ça fait 29 et 1
ça fait trente et trois ça fait 33 ça
veut dire si je me suis pas planter
comme j'ai pris le plus gros suivi de
tous les plus petites sa ligne que le
plus petit résultat possible serait 33
donc je sais que mon addition est
forcément aussi 33 je prends des notes
parce que c'est pas si bête ce que je
suis en train de lire vous savez qu au
moment où je vous parle je crois dans
attendez je vérifie l1 ainsi au moment
où je vous parle je suis pas là je suis
en vacances en fait je suis pas là j'en
reviens bientôt
ce qui n'empêchera pas les vidéos de
sortie en mon absence et après je vous
retrouve aussi à partir de janvier et
février en tournée ou est-ce que je vais
être en spectacle je reprends la tournée
après à partir du 18 janvier où je vais
être la guerre 1 marseille à buc mais ça
c'est déjà complet à coudekerque branche
à florange à bordeaux as ribeauville à
saint-etienne mais c'est également
complet à besançon etc etc
vous êtes toutes les dates dans la barre
d'infos vous avez un lien vers mon site
où il ya toutes les dates la carte c'est
plutôt pas mal fait et merci à toutes
celles et ceux qui va découvrir ce que
je fais sur scène c'est quand même mon
vrai métier de faire l'humour et du
mentalist sur scène donc c'est toujours
très cool ou de l'inde et les salles
c'est un bonheur et je reviens à paris
au mois d'avril où êtes vous bref
reprenons j'ai dit le plus petit chiffre
très mal écrit fabien le plus petit
chiffre possible ses 33 peut-être en
appliquant pareil je peux avoir le plus
gros chiffre possible si on fait 17 et
13 30 et 22 52 59 79 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 67
ans puisque ça ça ça fait 60 70 6 79 le
plus gros c'est 79
ok on sait que le résultat que je
cherche pour faire des tranches départ
de la même valeur et forcément compris
entre 33 79 sauf erreur de ma part mais
même s'il ya une roche s'offre est loin
de hay un 2e 27 là je n'ai pas vu un bon
ça tu vois ça ça peut peut-être générer
les rats mais je sais entre tous bien ça
peut pas être un des extrêmes donc on
est on est au milieu de ça donc
imaginons qu'on parte du 10 ans lui
disent c'est pas très haut on va lui
mettre que des pas très haut 10 17
là ça fait 14 ans monte vite quand même
on va remettre indice est encore un
disque ça nous fait 10 20 30 40 47
qu'est ce qu'on a à côté si je me mets
là sur cette tranche et que je venais
1,47
j'ai dit ça ça fait vingt parce que je
déduis déjà un la dent matériaux donc là
ça fait vingt ça fait trente et un
ça fait 36 et 6 42 c'est pas si mal là
comme ça hein 47 42
voilà après la la ça pêche graff quoi ça
fait 10 12 14 20 là ça fait que 20 bon
là on a de trop gros écarts ça ne peut
donc pas être ça mais comme j'ai un trop
gros écart je commençais juste à
travailler comme ça sur une tranche on
va voir ce que ça donne
je sais que là ça me fait un gros écart
mais si je fais ça ça me continent fait
un bruit cas alors je peux peut-être
mettre le trait ici si je mêle très ici
ça me fait 10 et 17 27 je reprends
toujours les trois mêmes tranches l'un
pour voir donc 27 37 37 et 6 ça nous
fait 43
donc on a on a baissé un petit peu celle
ci ici ça nous fait toujours 20 pts
ça ça ça nous fait 20 on fait toujours
31-36 a pas bougé ça d'accord
le trente six à neuf les 42 donc ça
c'est pas mal on n'est pas loin mais là
on reste toujours trop faible 10 nous
fait 12 ça nous fait 14
ça nous fait 17 ça nous fait 27 on a
monté mais c'est toujours pas assez donc
il faudrait que j'aie incrémente un peu
plus de valeur de ce côté là si j'y mets
le 16 donc j'ai gardé les mêmes comme sa
jumelle eu 16 à lui et le 17 à lui et je
retravaille toujours sur les mêmes
franche je procéder comme ça dix essais
ça nous fait 26 et 6,36 et 6 42 19 et 12
ça nous fait 31 3 38 48 58 ha ha c'est
trop ça savait trop là ça va décoller
lui va y va décoller beaucoup trop fort
donc il faudrait que je bouge
ah non lui il est lié à lui à la limite
on va faire un truc comme ça pour voir
ok je re bouge je reprends toujours de
lui je me fais un petit point pour m'en
souvenir 10 et 16 26 et un 27 37 37 et 8
ça nous fait 45
on reste toujours on navigue dans les
mêmes eaux ça ça nous fait toujours 19
et 12
vous vous souvenez pour moi ça fait 20
et 11 donc 31 et 6,36 et 10,46 c'est pas
mal on n'a qu'un d1 d'écart entre ces
deux-là 10 et 17 ça nous fait 27 et 10
qui nous font 37 hockey ou suivis jusque
là et 3 qui nous font 40 et 4,44
c'est pas mal du tout du coup je vais
continuer on va aller dans des eaux on
n'a jamais de la ligue et le 13 et le
dise ça nous fait un 3 à 10 33 et 6,39
il n'y a pas un gros quart de fou 10 et
de 12 et 5 17
[ __ ] les 6 23 alors là par contre
l'aca pêche bon ce que je vois en tout
cas c'est qu'on est toujours on avoisine
pas loin des 40 un peu en dessous un peu
au dessus goethe et essayer de faire un
quart ont directement ici tous les jours
à partir de ma ligne de départ ça nous
fait 10 26 1 2 sûr que non si je mets là
ça nous fait 27
mais là il nous faudra 10 pas mal parce
que g13 kepa bowie et 17 27 et 10 37 et
30 40
là je me fais un 40e' ici on a 40 mais
ici j'ai même pu a compté là je vois
bien que j'ai trop en dessous là je vois
bien que c'est largement au dessus
puisque j'ai déjà 50 de reins cassés de
la donc 62 je vais tâtonner je vais
essayer des pistes et je propose à
partir de maintenant sous un air léger
mais détendue un d'accélérer et on
arrêtera l'accélérer quand j'aurai
quelque chose d'important à dire dans le
bien ou dans le malt et ses accents du
sud
[Musique]
on enlève le regardant si loïc je crois
que je tiens quelque chose j'ai pas
encore tous vers écrire j'enlève le
ralenti du coup tous avec toi ralenti je
lui donne tellement longue que ça je me
dis ok ça ça fait dix sept et trois ça
fait 20 c et 4 c très bien ça fait
quarante et je regarde juste à côté je
me dis à temps mais devient ça fait 3 et
27 30 et 10 40 est en fait du coup 3 et
17 ça nous fait vingt et quinze et vingt
ça fait grâce à fait 40 donc là j'ai ces
trois là qui font la même somme
là on a 27 et deux ça nous fait 29 et
sympa dommage ça ne fonctionne pas mais
alors à temps at là c'est le dit ce qui
fait que ça fonctionne sur 40 avec ces
deux là mais il ya 2 10 sur les ailettes
donc il ya peut-être qu'en changeant de
10 d'un ça change rien ça ça fait quoi
ça ça fait 11 et 9 ça nous fait 20 et 7
27 et 13 40
alors qu'en france qu'on là je pense que
c'est 40 lalla salma chercher trois sets
ça fait 19 et le 1 2 4 ça fait vingt
nous reste 3 3 et 17 ça fait vingt ça
nous fait bien 46 fait un petit chèque
qu'elle devient ça fait 3 et 27 ça nous
fait 30 et 10-40 chèque blanc 3 et 17 ça
fait 20 15 et 5 sa fait 20ans forme ça
fait quarante plaintes chez moi allez
vas-y aux tchèques
bré 27 et 2c nous fait 29 5 et 11 5 et 6
a fait 11 et 29 ça fait bien 40
britney c'est pas mal c'est par hasard
je pense qu'on est bon la 20 et 2 ça
nous fait 22 14 et 4 ça fait dix-huit
l'ensemble ça fait 40 11 et 9 ça nous
fait 20 c'était très ça fait vingt ça
fait bien 40 donne 7 et 2 ça nous fait
29 6 et 5 baies comme tout est là c'est
qu'à rendre partout caron sur les 16 de
trucs là du tout c'est bâclé ça s'est
réglé ça met au point le chevalier du
zodiaque je vais faire comment s'était
fait ça
et il fait après pégase commencer
maintenant celui qui fait ça en plus
c'est singh après vous êtes ce truc très
élégant alain pouvoir du cygne [ __ ]
c'est trop cool alors déjà faut les gens
sur amazon vous savez ce site qui disent
que la solution miracle en fait à marche
pas actuellement erreur fatale erreur
quoi venez voir la vidéo ça fonctionne
j'offre ce casse-tête à toute personne
ayant comme prénom euclide sous réserve
qu'ils m'envoient une pièce d'identité
cole et sinon je vous l'offre sur
instagram jeu bien aimé ça change
j'en ferais pas tous les jours on est
comme ça mais ça change la semaine
prochaine vous donne rendez vous
mercredi à 6 heures mais il y aura une
vidéo
quoi qu'il arrive entre temps vendredi
ou samedi donc soyez là à vigilant
attentif
loïc moreau bonjour je mets au défi de
la semaine prochaine heitz-- casse tête
ok portez vous bien abonnez vous en
cliquant ici c'est hyperimportant
abonnez-vous on est proche du million ce
serait dommage de pas faire il y va ou
pas omis guillon ici vous avez la vidéo
du casse-tête de la semaine dernière sur
lequel j'ai un petit ou traquer un peu
comme la maintenant et ici vous avez une
vidéo qui va vous intéresser parce que
c'est le gorille thm de youtube qui le
choisira pour votre show